this is coda a three-year-old African  cheetah critically endangered less than  8,000 remain in the wild the African  cheetah is built for speed it's the  world's fastest land animal  clocking 0 to 60 miles per hour in a  mere 3.4 seconds long and lean with a  flexible spine they use their tail as a  rudder steering when running after prey  they stalk their prey  under the bright Sun of the African  savannah the tear marks that run across  their face help reflect the glare of the  Sun much like football players apply  paint beneath their eyes before a game  they once roamed across all of Africa  but today are found in less than a  quarter of their historic range habitat  loss poaching and loss of prey are all  threats to this beautiful cat this is  the African cheetah